- [Voiceover] Hello
grammarians and hello Paige.
- Hi David.
- Today we're gonna be talking
about commas in correspondence
and what that means is how to use commas
in letter writing, so saying
hello and saying goodbye.
When you start writing letter
or an e-mail to somebody,
you use commas so let
me show you an example.
So if you're writing a letter to someone
you open it with something like this.
Dear Prudence comma
I received the plum jam you sent me.
You can see we have this little comma here
because what commas do,
right, is that they separate
elements of the sentence from one another.
So what we're doing
here with this comma is
we're putting it after the
greeting to separate it
from the body text. So
that's how you begin
a letter or an email
with a comma after the, you know,
dear part or the hello Prudence comma part
you know, whatever it is,
but Paige, how do you use
commas toward the end
of correspondence of emails and stuff?
- Great, so at the end
of a letter or an email
you'll use a comma in
a sort of similar way
to how you use it at the beginning
so you'll say something like with love
comma
Bruce Ben-Bacharach
- So okay, we can use them
at the beginning like this.
Dear Prudence comma
or we can use it at the end.
The endings of letters.
So this has a technical name.
We were discussing this
before we started recording
so if you open a letter,
that's called the salutation
which is another way to say hi
and the way you end a letter
is called a valediction
which is like
saying hail, I think
wale in latin means hail.
I think salu is hello
and wale, or vale is goodbye
and so this is really just like a
helloining and a goodbye saying
so if you're saying hello
in a letter or an email
you use a comma. If you're saying goodbye
in a letter or email...
- Use a comma.
- You can learn anything. David out.
- Paige out.